[Musica]
Oggi faremo una mega Challenge
nascondino con due classi di scuola
per il primo round io e Vitale Ci
nasconderemo e tutti Voi dovrete
trovarci Chi vincerà questa Challenge
vincerà un mega premio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un secchio intero di dolci e caramelle
Ma lo devo prendere adesso se no te l'ho
rubata no no no no no no no questo è il
premio di chi vincerà la Challenge ma
adesso sbrighiamoci perché dobbiamo
iniziare con il primo round dobbiamo
nasconderci Voi siete pronti
e per il primo round poi vi metterete
qui a contare fino a 30 e noi ci andremo
a nascondere
[Musica]
Però mi raccomando dovete chiudere gli
occhi e non dovete guardare dove andiamo
a nasconderci non potete barare Mi
raccomando ci saranno anche le guardie a
controllarvi
[Musica]
Sì infatti chi bara in questa Challenge
verrà arrestato con le manette Quindi mi
raccomando non Barate Ma ora siete
pronti per il
primo round piani
[Musica]
Ok ragazzi
tutto qua
un po' che non è uscito subito Vediamo
quanto tempo ci mettono a trovarci
sento dei passi
guardiamo
sono nascosta abbastanza bene ma che
stai dicendo ho detto ti sei nascosta
malissimo cioè c'è c'è c'è un sacco di
Non lo so non so dove mettermi per
nascondermi Forse è meglio se stiamo un
po' qui e poi dopo ci spostiamo e
cambiamo nascondiglio perché ho paura
che qui ci scopriranno subito vedi è
solo una stanza Forse è meglio andarci a
nascondere non posso più che un
pochettino più buio dove magari ci
possiamo nascondere meglio che ne pensi
Ho paura che se riusciamo da questa
stanza incontreremo tanti bambini e ci
troveranno subito Fidati di me Dai
andiamo
ok abbiamo cambiato nascondiglio stiamo
dietro a questa porta Speriamo che non
si trovino
andiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Dai andiamo
a comandare
[Musica]
andiamo
a smascherati ci avete trovato bravi noi
eravamo nascosti là dietro la porta poi
all'inizio siete passati non ci avete
visto però poi quando siete tornati
indietro ci avete trovato Avete vinto il
primo round
ma adesso per il secondo round dovete
nascondervi Voi siete pronti
[Musica]
e per questo secondo round io e vitale
dovremo trovare più bambini possibili
tutti i bambini che io troverò dovranno
entrare qua nel quadrato Viola invece i
bambini che troverò Vitale dovranno
venire qui in questo blu chi avrà
trovato più bambini in questo secondo
round vincerà il round siete pronti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ok io evitare conteremo fino a 30 e voi
dovete iniziare a nascondervi andiamo
[Musica]
11 11 12
siamo pronti a trovarvi dovevi
nascondendo Ah c'è tantissimo silenzio
Dove saranno andati Sì è incredibile
tutto questo silenzio adesso Beh ma
ricordati che siamo in competizione
adesso devo trovare più bambini Io no io
devo trovare più bambini dovevo prendere
tutto quel paese lì no vado io a cercare
più bambini di Vitale sento dei rumori
di plastica qualcuno sta scappando
Ok che abbiamo qui Qui non c'è nessuno
[Musica]
Mi è venuta un'idea posso cercare le
sedie Eh ma no non c'è niente qui oppure
posso cercare del cibo magari qualcuno
ha dimenticato il cibo qui in mezzo
sento qualcuno che sta ridendo da questa
parte
ho visto qualcuno
provate viva c'è qualcun altro qua
dentro prendi aiuto sarà in altri
bambini nascondi qua dentro andate nel
quadrato Viola ok
[Applauso]
Oddio chi c'è qua
ho trovato due
nascondini due bambini nascosti Ok
allora dove dovete andare voi adesso nel
quadrato bravissimi nel quadrato blu Oh
Siamo due a due Guardate due nel cerchio
Rosa ciao
e due che ho trovato io nel cerchio blu
Guarda non ci posso credere Io ho
trovato qui che ho trovato qui li ho
trovati tre forse sono in vantaggio
Arisa abbiamo trovato quattro io ne ho
trovati cinque ok Ho già trovato un po'
di bambini Credo di essere in vantaggio
ma
[Musica]
vi ho trovato e non vogliono togliersi
dal nascondiglio
e Ciao Vi ho trovato
bravissimi andate inquadrato Viola Mi
raccomando non in quello blu se non
prende i punti Vitale continuiamo a
cercare
no parità 5 Ferrarini da 5 per Vitale
non ci posso credere c'è qualcuno qui
c'è qualcuno qui due e il voltaggio
vitale per il momento
c'è qualcuno qui c'è qualcuno qui
quadrato blu e qui che c'è C'è qualcuno
anche qui non ci credo mi da lei
supermontaggio
[Applauso]
Vitale il super vantaggioso
Vitale leader
Ninja
stanno per andare in vantaggio loro
presto presto devo giocare altro
e qui c'è qualcuno
non ce ne sono andiamo a vedere chi c'è
qua
Ehi Vitale sta già cercando io i bambini
qua tu fai da un'altra parte eh Sei
andato in vantaggio devo cercare altri
bambini un momento stai vincendo tu
ah ah
sì sì eh Ho sentito dei rumori provenire
da qua ma è super buio non credo che ci
sia qualche bambino nascosto qua al buio
fa troppo paura
controlliamo lo stesso Vediamo
se nessuno
aiuto Guardate quanto è buio c'è
qualcuno ah
Ah veramente nascosti al buio Ma siete
super coraggiosi presto presto presto
presto presto andate nel quadrato viola
erano nascosti nel buio più totale sono
coraggiosissimo questi bambini Vitale
sta cercando i bambini nella mia zona
devo sbrigare aiuto
Lasciami in pace però
Ehi ma non mi seguire anche qui adesso
eh vediamo nel frattempo Quanti punti ho
fatto io Quanti punti ha fatto di tanto
non riesco a capire se sono in vantaggio
io Vitale Comunque dobbiamo trovare il
resto dei bambini Ok abbiamo completato
il secondo round e purtroppo non siamo
riusciti a trovare loro ma dove arrivate
nascostissimo
No vabbè non abbiamo trovato loro
davanti
a nascondervi Infatti adesso andiamo a
contare quanti bambini ho trovato io nel
cerco io Viola nel quadrato Volevo dire
il quadrato Viola vediamo quanti siamo
alzate tutti una mano Qua ci stiamo 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 5 like e adesso
Vediamo quanti ne ha trovati Vitale
contiamo invece Quanti ne ha trovati
Vitale 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
Siccome io evitare non siamo riusciti a
trovare loro tre gli ultimi bambini che
erano rimasti in realtà Avete vinto voi
Avete vinto voi i bambini
per questo terzo round faremo Femmine
contro maschi quindi Team Vitale
contratti Marina e se voi fate parte del
team Anita lasciate un mi piace se
invece
[Risate]
fate parte del team Vitale iscrivetevi
al canale
[Applauso]
[Musica]
adesso loro contano e noi ci andiamo a
nascondere ok
Come facciamo per trovare tutti ci
dividiamo tutti qua Sì sì
Secondo me qualcuno vuole stare
sicuramente con Anita Sì lo so che
volevo
Magari possiamo stare due a due e allora
lo so che volete stare con me però se
state tutte con me poi non riusciamo a
trovarli tutti
Ho scoperto tutti i nascondigli avete
sentito che stanno copiando la strategia
anche loro vogliono separarci Che cosa
c'è
Scusate eh lo vedremo fra un po' Chi
vincerà la tavola
1 2 andiamo a nasconderci
dietro andiamo a contare presto andiamo
a raccontare
tanto vinceremo noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
andiamo avanti Eccolo dobbiamo trovarli
tutti
[Musica]
Ciao papà
bello
ma dietro non c'è nessuno
[Musica]
Aspetta
vediamo se c'è qualcuno qua c'è nessuno
No non c'è nessuno presto presto
sbrighiamoci presto
non se ne sono accorte sono passate da
qui ma non c'è più niente
non troviamo più nessuno
ok torniamo di là allora
[Musica]
le mie ragazze ne hanno trovato un bel
po' ma non credo che li hanno trovati
tutti
[Musica]
quanti sono
[Applauso]
abbiamo trovato tutti
Allora proviamo a vederlo Ok Ci manca
solo una persona vitale da trovare se lo
troviamo fermo avremmo vinto che sarà
presto andiamo presto l'avete trovato Sì
dov'è Dov'è dov'è
Oh no ciao ciao
è uscita fuori fuoco
Vieni fuori ti abbiamo trovato ormai
presto ok noi femmine abbiamo trovato i
maschi
[Applauso]
Sì
tanto nel prossimo round vinceremo noi è
vero Sì
[Applauso]
C'è troppo paccano qua dentro
qua ci sono delle regole molto serie e
voi avete esagerato Le regole vanno
rispettate per cui adesso finisce qui è
chiaro finisce qua stop
Cioè dobbiamo finire la Challenge non ci
interessa il regolamento e il
regolamento avete esagerato Mi dispiace
finisce qui
Come mai è normale che facciamo rumore
Siamo tantissimi che cosa
facciamo oggi
dobbiamo dobbiamo
mangiare Sì sì raga Le case Sì li
dobbiamo fare
senza farvi vedere dalle guardie Andate
tutti a cercare le cose Ok mandate
andate andate e ci penso io a parlare
con loro eh Ok non c'è problema allora
adesso ce ne andiamo visto che avete
detto che abbiamo infranto le regole
adesso ce ne andiamo ok sì bene così va
bene così è giusto così perché le regole
vanno
rispettate Va bene va bene ce ne andiamo
allora Ma cosa stanno architettando a
gente rock e qui c'è qualcosa di strano
commissario Smith
la cosa puzza un po'
C'è troppo silenzio
e ora siete pronti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Vi porto tutti insieme
[Applauso]
oddio oddio oddio oddio oddio oddio
oddio oddio oddio aiuto
benissimo Ora che abbiamo risolto questo
problema delle guardie perché le avete
legate bravissimi Adesso possiamo
continuare con la nostra Challenge che
cosa ne pensate
Ah ah ah
devo andare ancora avanti
[Musica]
per la nostra Challenge ciao
[Applauso]
Ehi Guardate
wow wow wow
[Applauso]
basta
mi arrendo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ce l'abbiamo fatta ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok con i round che abbiamo completato e
con la Challenge che abbiamo fatto
abbiamo deciso che avete vinto tutti
questa sera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Challenge completata